what I also appreciated about your story
which I related to so much is once I had
kids I was like I've got to change all
my behaviors but it took a long time but
it was my kids that really inspired me
to go okay I need to be a person of
accountability and safety mhm is that
what it was for you it it w I definitely
think that I made that decision to stop
drinking at at once I knew that when I
put alcohol in my body I'm unpredictable
and I want to be predictable for my kids
yeah and I loved how you talked about
like sometimes you would black out or
sometimes you know you wouldn't remember
things or you'd go to work like hung
over like I would just tell myself like
oh that's just normal that's just come
what comes with the territory yeah I
mean I was blacking out from drinking
when I was 14 when I first started
drinking I had blackouts where I didn't
remember the night before and it was so
many years later that I heard that
that's not normal cuz I was like well
it's alcohol it's a chemical science
like you lose your m
yeah I'm like I've been doing this my
whole life I think I've got it down now
thank you yeah I went on vacation and
one of my friends had to pull me out of
the bushes you know yeah and it's funny
right and we laughed about it but like
deep down inside I was like God I wish I
wasn't the only one who was found in the
bushes on our trip you know when things
are going really well for me I always
bring up the
bushes okay so how about like with with
your husband like how did you guys get
on a track that was
same page but also different behaviors
in life his problem was not your problem
your problem is not his problem well it
it was hard at first because my husband
didn't have a drinking problem but I I
thought he might just because he drank
along with me but once I quit drinking I
was like oh he's normal that's
disappointing I know yeah I know